Nope.
Yes.
Stupid Pass.
Then you've got the arms left.
Yes,
I have
just a flesh wound in life.
When somebody gets injured,
it's just a stroke of bad luck.
But in movies,
it's never an accident.
An injury is a calculated and meaningful
choice by a writer or director to tell
us more about a character or reinforce
certain thematic ideas.
Each injury,
whether it's blindness or becoming
handicapped,
represents the symbolic handicap captain
who they are as a character.
And many of the most memorable
characters and movie moments were
greatly enhanced by this literary
concept.
So let's give some characters at
diagnosis.
Oh No,
I just keep bringing it up.
What do you get back in again?
First,
I have to convince you that injuries are
much more than just physical in the
film.
So let's say we have a character
returning from combat adjusting to
civilian life.
How do we show his inner conflict
symbolically?
Give him a limp.
A limp literally hinders his mobility,
reflecting his struggle to adapt to this
new lifestyle.
Um,
I know that you'll therapist thing,
so limp psychosomatic,
correct camera,
right?
So when he gets the thrill of the chase
and the limp finally goes away,
we know what that means.
You said you forgot this.
The ability to stand and walk normally
is a symbol of strength and self
confidence.
Why do you think the secret service
didn't allow any pictures taken of FDR
in a wheelchair?
Walking or the lack of it makes for a
powerful image in forrest gump.
Lieutenant Dad's character arc.
It gets represented through his
injuries.
He wants to die a hero on the
battlefield.
When he fails,
he loses the ability to walk.
His injury directly contrasts forrest
who went from handicap to always running
in later scenes.
Lieutenant Dans frustration is always
shown through his reliance on others to
move because he can't move himself where
he wants to be.
When he finally gets as close as he can
to the heavens,
challenging the fate he was supposed to
have.
That's when he finally moves on his own
and eventually I got new legs custom
made titanium alloy.
The fixing of an injury always reflects
the way a character,
his inner self is being fixed too.
If you want to character to have a
crutch in their psyche,
give them a literal one.
There will be blood starts with theory
scenes depicting the dangerous world of
drilling underground.
Daniel plainview breaks is like falling
into a well and has to crawl all the way
from the well in the middle of nowhere
to the nearest town through an injury
and how he beats it.
We learned about his ruthlessness better
than dialogue could ever tell us.
It's in a way that justifies his actions
in the movie as much of a bastard as
this man proves himself to be that
courage that it would have taken to do
that actually gives him the heroic right
for almost everything that he does
throughout the rest of the movie.
But it doesn't always have to be
grandiose.
You can even give a character a fake
injury to play with our expectations.
Bonnie and Clyde Clyde cutoff his toe to
get out of doing work in prisons,
and this impairment relates directly to
sexual impotence with Bonnie in
literature and film.
A physical ailment can often indicate a
sexual element.
For a man,
he's limped in more ways than one.
I ain't much of a loverboy in rear
window.
Jeff is physically bound to a
wheelchair.
He doesn't want to marry you.
Lisa and his physical restrictions from
his injury compliment his view that he's
perhaps being sexually restricted as
well
off to act,
but what about characters like professor
x and Yoda?
They both have issues with walking,
but there's some of the most powerful
characters in their worlds.
I think a lot of mentors have physical
handicaps because it reflects how they
pay for mind over body.
They've transcended physical limitations
to the point where it doesn't reflect
weakness,
a similar injury,
his blindness,
this trope goes as far back as oedipus
rex when the blind man can tell the
future.
While oedipus is the ones seeing things
incorrectly in movies,
not being tricked by the world around
you seems to give you a spiritual wisdom
instead.
Also,
have you ever noticed that every
superhero has a movie where they lose
their powers,
they can't shoot webs,
they don't have their suit or they get
blasted with Kryptonite?
It's because when your life is
threatened to when you're no longer
invincible,
benny become relatable because what's
more human than being mortal when to
pretty much invincible superheros fight.
It's kind of boring.
Where are the stakes?
How can we relate to them?
Iti was such a revolutionary movie
because for the first time the Ilien
wasn't a giant monster,
huge impenetrable creature.
He was innocent and most importantly he
could get sick making him human.
I think one of my favorite examples of
bringing out humanity through injuries
is in terminator two Arnold
Schwarzenegger is an emotionless robot,
but by the end of the movie he grows on
you and it comes from his selflessness
and how he lets himself get hurt.
Even with no sympathetic dialogue and no
discernible emotion and a murderer
streak.
The terminators still gets a hug in the
end and we empathize with him because he
got hurt.
You know what?
Here's the thing about die hard,
die hard one.
The original John McLean,
just this normal guy,
you know,
he's just a normal New York City cop who
gets his feet cut and gets beat up,
but he's an everyday guy and die hard
for,
he is jumping a motorcycle into a
helicopter air,
you know,
he's invincible.
At the end of the day,
major injuries reminds you of your
mortality and may make you reconsider
what's important to you and film the
same principles apply.
So the next time somebody gets hurt,
remember that it's never just a flesh
wound.
Come back here and take off kind of by
though.
Thanks for watching.
You
said.